[Music]
Michael Jackson's children 20 year old
Prince Michael and 19 year old Paris
they made a rare red carpet appearance
together last night the siblings held
hands as they posed on the red carpet
Paris wore Zac Posen gown and was in a
relaxed mood lip-synching to an eagle
song before the event the two attended
the mothers to mothers and the Elizabeth
Taylor's AIDS Foundation dinner
Taylor was Michael's close friend and
was godmother to Paris and Prince next
month marks the 35th anniversary of the
release of Michael's Thriller last night
both his brother Jackie and father Joe
attended a bash to celebrate the release
of Michael's new Scream album which
features remastered versions of Thriller
and blood on the dance floor
[Music]
what would Michael think of the fact
that we're still celebrating Thriller
and all his music decades later well I
think it's fantastic all the work and
the hard work he put into everything
really pays off in the long run so I'm
glad it's happening and with the rumors
about Janet Jackson possibly returning
to the Super Bowl halftime show with
Justin Timberlake sources close to Janet
tell ET there's nothing to consider and
that there is no offer to perform with
Justin adding right now Janet is
concentrating on touring and that's it
[Music]
you